hard to believe what's happening in
America we thought we'd check in with
the man on the Leading Edge of America
in the city of Los Angeles which is
always ahead of national Trends a
lifelong resident City Adam Carolla we
always see when we're in townhouse the
Adam Carolla show
to put this into perspective Adam thanks
so much for coming on so what's your
view of what we're watching well it's
fine I I'm sorry I don't have any new
thoughts because you're 200 guests
before me I think encapsulated every
thought you could possibly have about
this but like Whitlock said I think
there's a religious angle to this I
think they on the left that is a
religion and I think they look at Trump
as Satan yes and it if you got to get
rid of Satan and or Hitler then you just
do what you got to do God is on your
side so there's a kind of feel that
right I mean I don't I don't I feel that
too I don't think I'm imagining well it
is like this isn't politics Trump
derangement syndrome feels like the kind
of anger you would have against a
religion and a religious leader who
didn't agree with your religion and then
you need to take them down you know
incarcerate them whatever it is and so
all the rule book is out the window when
you're dealing with Satan Hitler or
Beelzebub or whoever so I think there's
that element to it the other one is kind
of interesting which is we make
proclamations like Merrick Garland says
white supremacy is the biggest problem
this country faces in the most danger of
this country faces everyone laughs at
him and then he goes out and finds it so
then he goes and arrests parents at
Virginia school board meetings right so
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy so
they're going to turn Trump into a
martyr people are going to go out and
protest somebody's going to do something
stupid and then they're going to fire up
the doj just like January 6 but outside
now and and snap into action so they
make proclamations and then they need to
find the crime and then we'll find this
so certainly people are going to push
back someone's going to do something
stupid or not CNN MSNBC the answers from
the few they're all going to blow it up
into this yes and then the Stormtroopers
so it does feel like the population is
being pushed into a corner for a reason
I'm not just imagining that I feel like
it's to get them to react so that the
government can now swoop in and do a
self-fulfilling prophecy because
everybody reacts to this is going to be
a white supremacist and remember we told
you that white supremacy is the biggest
problem this country faces how long can
they scream at whites before that just
becomes ineffective
it it it's like I've said it a million
times there's never been a better time
to be called a racist you could just be
lumped in with everyone else in this
country anyone who voted Republican and
to your other point I think the only way
this stops is if LeBron James and the
Obamas and the view ladies and Joe
Scarborough if people start speaking up
not people on the right no people on the
left like you need some sane cultural
leader who's an athlete or Oprah or
someone of that nature to start going
look I don't like Trump but I love the
country this isn't right we need to do
something because aren't you supposed to
settle it in your elections isn't that
how a democracy work you don't like
Trump okay fine then you get to vote
against him right I thought what if Joe
Biden was running running against the
devil
then how would you want to say you're
exactly right well then you need to get
the angels of the Lord in there Alvin
Bragg uh
you did that a lot by the way even after
our 100 guests Adam cruel it's wonderful
to see you good to see you thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight